meine gehirnzellen streiten sich gerade
darum wer als erster selbstmord begehen
darf allemal haben ist luca meine liebe
freunde ich habe bereits mehrmals auf
dumme reagiert und da diese reactions
immer mega gut bei euch an kamen habe
ich mir heute das video ausgesuchte
damals meisten den kindergeburtstag
ja da gibt es wahrscheinlich nur fleisch
wurst zu essen wieder drei sekunden sind
wir drin
und sie ist wieder nur am fressen beim 1
becher ohne früchte bestellen weil
schokolade reicht die reaction wollen
wir darauf nicht gesehen habe habe ich
hier oben noch mal verlinkt du bist
wirklich der absolute meisterkoch
qualifizierungs geburtstag selbst
organisieren
jetzt schicke ich erst dass sie den
geburtstag von ihrer eigenen tochter
organisiert
erst mal finde es eigentlich ganz süßer
sich darüber gedanken die dome wird in
dieser folge also mit kindergeburtstag
für ihre tochter organisieren macht sich
jetzt schon gedanken was das gewisse
extra an den geburtstag sein kann
oh mein gott juli das ist der laden wo
wir unser münchen
falls euch übrigens fragt er hier
einfach weil sie diese spots so
gemütlich findet ja hast du gewusst die
hatten auch diese tolle bilder von dem
feld stehen fand ja sowas von colin
hätte man so schön mit süßigkeiten
füllen könnt und leonie darauf
einprügelten
geburtstag organisiert wird wohl vor
allem fühlen können das was hier
wirklich komplett wie viele auch
einkaufen ja alles denke der komplette
karte schon voll mit kuchen accessoires
[Musik]
der geist ist einfach fans haben weder
seine mich an wurde ich in amerika war
mit max die saas in kuba und sie hatte
irgendwie ihre tochter mit dabei und sie
sagte ja hier noch welche von diesem
vitamin bonbons und wir dachten halt so
sind aus apotheke irgendwie so vitamin a
zusatzmittel oder so und dann war es
halt einfach nimm 2 ja die dachte so
nimm 2 einfach vitamine pur locker das
doppelte auf den friseuren und seine
mutter eingeladen und die sind halt so
ein bisschen öko mäßigen kaufen hab ich
einfach weil der vitamin a c und e donna
der eine kippa kassel hatte vor gericht
doch mal genau so sieht es aus wenn man
vor gelassen wird in der kasse
nein mein gott
sie hat jetzt einfach kondome
aufgepustet all das mit den luftballons
es nicht geklappt hat
also wirklich damit das ist das ist
kindergeburtstags organisierung wenn
hier die nasa ist und hier spacex dann
bist du hier gleich sogar hier es sieht
aber eigentlich echt nicht so schlecht
aus oh mein gott meine gehirnzellen
streiten sich gerade darum wer als
erster selbstmord begehen darf dass
leoni die süße man sieht schon
ähnlichkeit zwischen den ball also die
dame hat jetzt die ganzen sachen für den
kuchen hier in das wohnzimmer geholt
das geburtstags immer von der leoni das
ist also das was kommen
ja
sie backten butter mit
den kuchen da also ist ein scheiß ernst
alter wie kann die das denn essen das
sind zehn eier mit zwei packungen
margarine immer noch ganz viel liebe
damit du bist mein vorbild koch
das ist das kann ich mir nicht anschauen
guck mal wieder alles auch rum liegt in
der bochumer wieder aussieht the dome
was ist denn mit dir und jetzt ist
fertig oder wodka wie schwarz dates
dicker als sie verbrannte scheiße
althaus sie da noch mehr schokolade
darauf die leoni hat er mein gott so auf
ihr alter guckt sie euch einfach an
damit du leider fehlt mir echt die worte
dann noch schoko dekoration das einer
kann gucken noch wirklich nicht so mein
gott hans marianne kommt leute jetzt
gehts aber sie ist noch richtig gut
und jetzt geht sie in das zimmer
aufgemacht hat die so braun im gesicht
war ja dass du keine küchen geboren
lediglich abgebracht
sommer nein action machen wir so ein
bingo her so ein paar sachen die auf
jeden fall gesagt werden oder auf jeden
fall passieren also was auf jeden fall
passiert es immer das soll sich mit
schokolade zu sein was noch immer
passiert ist dass marianne sagt was ist
denn hier passiert womit also julius
gerade zurückgekommen auf weitere bingo
sätze in die kommentare schreiben von
denen ihr denkt dass sie auch meiner
nächsten weg schon oft haben wir
vorkommt werden dann kuchen um zu
fressen
die sache ist wenn man mal ganz genau
auf dumme achtet auf damit die guckt
wirklich absurd so hinter die kamera
da steht dann wahrscheinlich leute die
lachen und die da muss man halt auch
lachen
die leoni tut mir echt ein bisschen leid
macht aber das ist dann guckt ihr war
das chaos an das kap du weißt du was ich
den hammer finde kaufen teppich liegt er
mixa noch in strobl und noch sind wir so
verdeckt so ist kann nicht noch
schlimmer kommen und dann liegt ein
eingestöpselt habe schokolade
verschmähter mix sagt er doch im strom
hängt
hoffentlich kann man nicht die kleinste
aufgabe geben ohne dass du es dir immer
weiter als wenn die einfach so und ohne
blick nur auf schlüssigkeit das heißt du
sollst nicht verstehen das ist der
geburtstagskuchen von leoni wer ist das
denn jetzt kommen jetzt schon die leute
sie hatten fucking klauen
[Musik]
ja
was wird da jetzt das ist wie ein
kindergeburtstag hat sie war im glauben
du solltest ein clown
vorstellbar wären kleine kinder
rumgelaufen wenn mein kind auf dieser
geburtstagsparty eingeladen wer und ich
werde mit gekommen ich wäre da nicht
mehr weggekommen voller rim hat du bist
ja auch wirklich dämlich weiße das
bestellst du hältst strippe also du hast
echt nicht erlauben warum weiß er da das
hätte mehr gleich auffallen cloud ist ja
auch immer geschminkt war gut wenn der
hier seinen arsch freilassung gegen wen
interessiert denn das gericht meint die
leoni tut mir ehrlich leid du rufst du
jetzt alle an sagt leonis krank und der
geburtstag fällt ins wasser
die leoni man irgendwie wollen wir
leonie adoptieren in zirka einer stunde
hätten die eltern mit den kindern vor
der türe stand und diese bude da reichte
keine aufrollen das hätte man entfernen
müssen und sanieren sowie das hieraus
sagen das war's also anscheinend gibt es
kein happy end die bude ist am arsch und
leonis geburtstag in reinster reinfall
aber er stellte mich das heutige video
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn euch meine reaction auf
damals super höchste klasse
organisierten kindergeburtstag gefallen
hat da geht diesem video gerne einen
daumen hoch und schreib mir unbedingt
eine weitere folge in die kommentare von
doppel auf die ich als nächstes
reagieren soll denn mir hat noch nie
etwas so viel spaß gemacht
[Musik]